tonight win las vegas releasing a
statement on some safety changes
following a deadly shooting tuesday
night that involved two employees
it happened in the employee parking
garage a worker killed 31-year-old
security officer
josef almonte before killing himself
joe moeller joins us now not too far
from that garage and joe you had
mentioned
during your report here at four o'clock
that the win was reviewing some of its
security protocols yes denise and just a
short time ago a representative from
windlaw stake vegas actually told me
that after reviewing their security
protocols they will now be equipping
their armed officers with body armor the
wife of the victim says he was wanting
this for years
tuesday's shooting in this garage is
leaving multiple families devastated and
now sparking change
[Music]
we got married last year marjorie
lamonte met her husband when she worked
at the wynn in 2018. we were going to el
salvador next month
their life plans together changed
forever tuesday night those words are
really true until death do us apart like
i never thought i was going to come so
soon you know joseph lamonte a wind
security officer responded to a welfare
call in the employee garage where
another employee
reggie taggett was sitting in a car the
guy opened the door and then shot him on
his torso
about eight bullets forty-two-year-old
taggett then turned the gun on himself
alemante says her husband loved helping
others he was a regular at this las
vegas jiu jitsu gym
she also tells me he liked working at
the wind but recent events this past
year were concerning him they were all
frustrated because they were scared
especially after that brawl that
happened last year at the encore
they got they were scared because they
realized this is out of control
that brawl in september videos and
photos went viral
i told myself what about aves and he's
like we have been
asking for like three years you know
everyone he's like everybody's scared
after reviewing protocols wynn announced
thursday they will be equipping armed
guards with ballistic body armor
that this could have saved my husband's
life
he would have never been dead it wasn't
his time to go
and marjorie did say that she is happy
to hear about these changes for her
husband's co-workers alemante is set to
be buried in new york where he is from
his friends have also set up a gofundme
to help with funeral expenses reporting
live here in las vegas joe mullen 8 news
now